I think there is,
there are some interesting faces,
um,
where people get it wrong and we know
why they got it wrong.
And this,
and this often occurs in the case when
you have very distinctive items.
And so this is one of the things that
once you kind of get expert at it,
you've got to watch out for cause it
cause as I say,
we are,
what we're looking for is we're looking
for patterns.
We're looking for overall patterns and
things that are distinctive by,
by nature of being distinct.
They're inconsistent with a patent,
but they'd draw your attention.
So we went into one of the rooms,
we went into everything,
indicated it was a socially responsible
person who was um,
uh,
a nice person.
Um,
they were um,
uh,
organized and together and um,
not that reckless.
We are pretty sort of conservative in
many ways.
Yet in the corner of the room there was
a plastic crate full of drug
paraphernalia or a bong for smoking
marijuana and stuff like that.
And of course the judges come in and
they see that which sticks out and they
go straight over to it and I likely to
interpret it,
you know,
make,
draw strong inferences from it.
Of course,
the very reason that makes it stick out
is the very reason they should have
ignored it.
And it turns out when I later found out
what was,
what was it doing there?
It turns out that this person was
holding onto the,
um,
uh,
have a roommate had gone traveling
around the world and tech.
Could you look after this stuff's good?
Yeah,
sure.
I'll put it on.
She put it responsibly,
put it in a crate and put it in the
corner of the room.
So,
you know,
it was,
it was consistent with above 90,
but not in the way you were thinking.